that yeah that was my honors and thesis
film and that that thing it was this
incredible experience where I lived on a
on a wine farm in in the Western Cape of
South African sort of lived with the
wine farm workers who are ethnically
colored which is a separate ethnic
category in South Africa not black or
white but historically the descendants
of the Millea slaves who were brought
over by the Dutch and the local poison
and traditionally they've always worked
on their on the wine farms and have had
a kind of paternalistic relationship
with the wine farm owners where they
were sort of you know didn't burn their
own houses or land and we often paid in
in wine and so the huge problems of
alcoholism so for me going in there
it was the beginning I think of my
disillusion actually with the process of
using film as a research tool I'm not
saying I wouldn't do it again but I
would be very wary of going into a
community as a as a white South African
with a video camera and clearly from a
different class and I sort of turned up
on these on these wine farms initially
and the farmer hadn't told the workers
that I would be filming and I'd assumed
he'd asked their permission and he sort
of said oh well she's gonna be filming
you so that makes three months of your
of your heart so you know over time then
you build a relationship with these
people and so it is this you know it
does become an incredibly important
experience in your life but I think it
also was quite disturbing because no
matter how good your intentions are that
power imbalance never goes away and if
you're not very careful I think it's um
it's very damaging
I think it's the Saints that I wouldn't
want to ever film in a community again
that I felt couldn't say no to me and
just the you know the history of South
Africa it was you know it's still too
recent
since this sort of paternalistic labor
relations system ended for me to really
feel like these workers in the community
have had enough sense of agency to feel
that they you know could tell me know at
certain moments so it was a constant
sort of I was trying to read it but you
know I than I thought that I was
actually overstepping boundaries because
they you know didn't feel like they had
a right to maintain those boundaries so
and I think if I ever did work in a film
project again I would I would pick a
community that was of a more similar I
would say class particularly class
background so that you thought that they
were always Co participants in
maybe not yeah maybe it wouldn't and
there's always the argument that you
know disenfranchised people need a voice
and their voices are silenced as it is
and that anything that can you know give
them a voice but again that the ethics
of doing that I'm not sure how it works
and I actually think it's a new
generation in South Africa of a black
middle class that is emerging emerging
at the moment and I think that's going
to very interesting generation to watch
just artistically I think they will be
able to create art that is indigenous in
a way that perhaps can sidestep some of
those collisions